don't waste food Christmas is a really
expensive time but with a little
understanding of finesse you can use up
every edible part of your Christmas
shopping just like we do in my
restaurant kitchens otherwise it's money
down the drain
[Music]
soups are one of the secrets in a chef's
Arsenal for delivering amazing flavor
whilst watching the pennies
my next recipe for Sumptuous pumpkin
soup uses the whole pumpkin the leftover
hamstock and I'm getting the kids
involved toasting the pumpkin seeds as a
snack nothing goes to waste in my
kitchen
but most importantly of all the soup
tastes absolutely delicious and with the
addition of sauteed wild mushrooms it's
fit to serve in my three mission style
restaurant
right listen I need some help okay we're
gonna make the most amazing pumpkin soup
Phil That's Heavy it's very heavy but it
is going to be absolutely delicious
right now you can always tell okay if
it's ripe
it was bang on there what does that
sound like
um drums that's right and if you push
your thumb in there
just a little bit of soft right at the
bottom of the root first of all I'm
going to cut it in half and very
carefully just cut through
I'm using a French pumpkin but these
versatile vegetables come in all shapes
and sizes and colors at this time of
year their nutty sweetness is ideal for
warming soups curries and roasts wait
and see what happens when we open this
up wow
oh right Holly that's for you now this
is where it's going to get a little bit
gory okay you've got your hands and you
scrape the seeds out
it's getting messy rub them together and
just give them a little clean nice and
gently good
yeah nice
look at that what do you mean yuck come
on Holly that's it into the water now
once the seeds are out we're going to
toast them in the oven as a little snack
so this is a really nice way I'm not
wasting anything
get your fingers right in there Tilly
there you go
[Music]
once the pumpkin seeds are out score the
flesh to help it roast and absorb flavor
season and had a generous amount of
Rosemary take the garlic rub around the
outside so it perfumes the inside then
add a large lug of olive oil and as a
garlic roast with a rosemary it's sweet
almost buttery nutty taste or mellow and
flavor the pumpkin all the seeds done
yeah almost good
after the pumpkin seeds have been
cleaned dry and season them ready for
the oven
now they're gonna roast in the oven for
about 45 to 50 minutes well done good
I'm waiting to smell the house in about
five minutes time to try please Holly
so
beautiful Australian right well done uh
big question have you wrapped mommy's
present yet no let's go I'll give you a
hand quickly
that garlic smells amazing
[Music]
Holly Tilly where's Holly he's going to
a party she's going to a party oh no any
boys there no I don't know oh you're so
diplomatic right look
today
are now toasted
see that
right have a little taste one of those
yeah but look at this wow
that
looks amazing and that is your roasted
pumpkin now
you put the spoon down the side okay
yeah scooping out well that all that
lovely
roast pumpkin we don't waste anything
hear that skin all into the center
roasting a pumpkin intensifies the rich
sweet flavor of its flesh which is
lovely for Soups but also great as a
filling for ravioli or making a
delicious Mash with butter nutmeg and
salt and pepper that's the pumpkin done
now what we need to do is get these
mushrooms here and just peel them
lengthways okay onto the plate again
I'll get my onion chopped
olive oil in
okay yeah nice and generous with olive
oil because I want this soup to do
really nice and velvety onions in
[Music]
and then scoop out
a wonderful garlic that's been roasted
on the pumpkin hmm
lovely a little bit of nutmeg on top of
the onions
onions garlic nutmeg yeah and now the
pumpkin
wow
and you would come in handy somewhere
this little baby
it's for you there you go perfect
now I want you just to grate some
Parmesan like that for me okay just so I
can start roasting off the parmesan as
well so we get this really nice rich
delicious
the pumpkin
Karma sounds brilliant for enriching
this soup it's mellow caramel flavor and
saltiness provide a lovely balance to
the Sweet pumpkin now what we need to do
all that in there okay
yeah good
[Music]
look at that now
that ah
smell that
roasted sort of cheesy Rosemary garlicky
yeah Olive oily beautiful so far
nothing's gone to waste we've used the
whole pumpkin now I'm gonna add the
stock my ham was cooked in
doesn't it it smells Christmassy
delicious
that's just from cooking our ham
bring that up to the boil
and let that cook out for 10 minutes
cream really important that it's boiling
when the cream goes in
okay you'll see the color lightning
so that's gonna give it a really nice
rich
creamy taste okay now we're going to
serve you the mushrooms
it would olive oil in there yeah
get nice and hot
we'll go first with the compa de la more
in you go
good girl then the Piedmont in
and then finally Chantal nice lovely I'm
going to put a little bit of butter in
there
we go good girl a little bit better
there nice I love the Deep complex
flavor of wild mushrooms but if you
can't get them Chestnut or filled
mushrooms still deliver Great Taste
mushrooms worked really well with
pumpkin because they have a warm earthy
flavor that complements the pumpkin
beautifully so
mushrooms into the center yeah yeah
from there
we get the parmesan
and just peel nice long layers
watch very carefully not just sit down
top on the parmesan
helps to season the mushroom
and really
give off
an amazing flavor
okay we're gonna blend the soup and all
we're going to do is half fill the
blender
so the soup gets really nicely aerated
now this is a bit of a naughty Chef's
trick a little knob of butter in there
just in top so when it Blends it gets
really nice and smooth lid on
onto the blender
and we'll just pulse it on and off first
wow and this is the moment we'll be
waiting for
just one side of the bowl
so that's Daddy's portion that
this little bit is yours now
a little taste blur it gently
done
[Music]
Sam's a real big hit in our household
over Christmas it's delicious so
versatile and tastes absolutely amazing
now we're going to do a delicious salmon
nicoise which is a really nice way of
reinvigorating your taste buds across
Christmas first of all we're going to
poach this in a really nice fragrant
caught booty on cool bullion is just a
fancy name for poaching liquor
first add fennel with this lovely
annotated flavor to water
then put in chopped celery onions and
salt
next pour in some white wine to give it
some body
add a splash of tarragon vinegar to give
it bite that wakes up everything that
really makes it sort of slightly acidic
but more importantly it goes brilliantly
well with the salmon to add flavor pop
in a couple of star anise and Crush
White peppercorns
freshness and Zing put in a handful of
parsley a couple of bay leaves and a
sliced lemon
and bring the liquid up to the boil and
slip in the salmon
no need to season it because the water
called boulung is all seasoned
beautifully stick that in
nice and gently skin side down
[Music]
salmon sweet delicate and Incredibly
flavoursome now it's going to go even
higher in terms of flavor simmer the
salmon for four to five minutes then
turn it off and let it cool down in the
liquid
salmon poached the next job is making
the light tarragon mayonnaise tarragon
mayonnaise with the difference first of
all
and make it to start off with one egg
yolk
a little bit of heat in there a teaspoon
of mustard
a little splash of tarragon vinegar in
whisk that first
nice big Bloom whisk
and then when the Bowl starts moving get
your cloth
open it up
just go around
and keep that on there that's not going
anywhere now
yeah
yeah what we've got to do first is whisk
nice and thick so we can take the oil
with one hand
sunflower oil in the other
thumb over the end
of the bottle tip it upside down slowly
drip it feed the oil in
whisk whisk whisk drip drip drip and
stop whisk and change hands that way
nothing's getting tired
whisk
drizzle the sunflower All In
stop
once you've got that nice base you can
add the oil quicker it's so easy
delicious when it's reached a luscious
thick consistency add a squeeze of lemon
juice and that's your basic mayonnaise
done
but I'm going to thin it down with water
because I want it much much lighter
almost like a vinaigrette which is
perfect for the salmon nicoise
still nice and creamy
now add chop tarragon The aniseed Taste
works really well with the eggs
and lemon zest to liven it up and now
the seasoning always at the end
salt pepper
and just mix that around look beautiful
it's got the texture of a custard almost
like a lemon curd
it's incredibly Rich it just falls off
the spoon it's traditional to use boiled
eggs and salad nicoise but I'm going to
do mine differently I'm going to cuddle
the eggs first put some water onto heat
then coat espresso cups or similar oven
proof containers with butter next season
each cup with pepper and lime with a
couple of basil leaves which gives the
eggs a lovely Herby note
[Music]
um
we're gonna season it
with a classic nicoise garnish anchovies
just roll that round
like a little ring and sit there at the
bottom of the basil then cracking your
eggs every little component going on
that plate
makes a big difference
making it up to that little extra
special level
place the espresso cups in a bath of
boiling water and bake in the oven for
about eight minutes
the yolks are still soft and creamy
with the eggs in the oven it's time to
bring the final components of the
nisswas together
to add color and freshness to the salad
marinate Chow tomatoes and olive oil
with shredded basil and lemon zest
the lemon goes brilliantly with the
salmon the Salmon's fragrant
just take those tomatoes even further
because this is a salad for winter I
want some of my ingredients to be hot
after parboiling potatoes and green
beans I sauteed them together give them
a little tough
what do you think of salad nice flowers
you think of a beautiful summer salad
exciting way of doing it now at
Christmas is having a really nice hot
mix well
when all the ingredients are prepared
it's time to bring the dish together and
dress the serving plate
the secret dressing
is starting from the center and working
your way out first of all
crispy salad leaves just
in the center
of your plate
what we do now is building a base I
don't want a flat salad I want a salad
with energy excitement and more
importantly I want something that looks
visually stunning slice the baby gem let
his hearts into wedges and lightly roll
them in the tarragon mayonnaise and this
is really important because in 10
minutes time this salad will still stay
nice and crisp buoyant exciting and more
importantly
Pack full of flavor next
I sauteed potatoes
around the outside I want the color now
I want the visual impact then I'm going
to sort of
Interlink the green beans
next add the marinated tomatoes and some
black olives
now for the exciting part removing the
eggs
from the espresso cup that little basil
leaf
is the crucial secret because that's
like a little blanket that slides it out
fingers crossed out
bang and I want that yolk
still nice and creamy inside the
saltiness from the anchovy it's almost
pureed at the bottom of that egg and
that nice fragrance sweet basil
almost like they've been rolled in
perfume delicious and finally the salmon
and just peel off
that skin wow the Silver Slipper
carefully flake the salmon and then
drape it on the salad
it's amazing salmon
over
you see the pinkness
incredibly aromatic and more importantly
every sliver of that salmon
and it tastes amazing
that is a perfect salmon nicoise for
Christmas
[Music]
morning in the Ramsay household always
starts with a late breakfast of
deliciously creamy scrambled eggs and
smoked salmon this recipe is a Ramsay
family tradition on Christmas Day
smoked salmon scrambled egg and
croissant it's Rich some just an
incredibly easy to do first the
croissants slice them into rounds and
season them lightly with salt and pepper
the secret behind a really good
breakfast
is in the timing on the quesles on first
smoke salmon on top and then the
scrambled egg put the croissants in a
dry pan and toast you don't need oil
because the croissants have a lot of
butter in them this is a great way to
transform day old croissants giving them
a delicious new life and just start to
see them toasting almost listening
in the pan and that's the butter
inside that smell is amazing it almost
smells like a sort of caramelized waffle
absolutely delicious I toast them all
around both sides
and then out next
just get the smoked salmon and sort of
twist it and let it fall over the castle
let it sit naturally on top of the
tofuessle
[Applause]
twist and over right scrambled eggs
eggs into the pan
never whip up the eggs beforehand
you break down the egg too much what I
want is a really nice rich creamy
scrambled egg eggs in no seasoning at
this stage a nice generous knob of
butter
now
from there
onto the Heat
and all we're going to do now is Stir
stir and stir and stir
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
texture to the eggs it looks Rich
delicious Sumptuous luxurious
be very careful making scrambled egg all
of a sudden it looks runny and within 30
seconds it's cooked working it all the
time
right after stirring a plastic scraper
in there take the pan off the heat
and just work around the pan cleaning up
all that scrambled egg that's sticking
to the bottom and now look we're getting
that really nice sort of creamy
beautiful texture a little touch of
butter in there now
I'm going to start with the seasoning
30 seconds on the end salt pepper
back on
to the stove and a tablespoon of cream
the cream actually stops the scrambled
egg from overcooking cream in
and then fold that in there now keep
that off the heat
but look at it look at that color
beautiful
and then finally some fresh chives
[Music]
is a Ramsay classic smoked salmon
toasted croissant and a delicious
scrambled egg
the best start to Christmas Day anyone
could wish for
foreign